[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday officials along the southern
border say mexican drug cartels are
moving much
larger shipments of drugs into the u.s
the amount of fentanyl
an especially dangerous substance that
was confiscated by the texas department
of public safety
jumped 800 percent in just one year
janet chamlion got an exclusive look at
one area where agents and state troopers
say it's harder to track drug smugglers
because more migrants are also crossing
the border
border patrol agent jerry galvan
oversees a desolate patch of the border
just west of el paso
a spot where he says 11 000 migrants
tried to enter the u.s
last month in fact this is the spot
where smugglers dropped sisters ages
three and five
over the 14-foot high barrier in april
it's very vast here correct what are you
seeing in terms of the cartel movement
well they're they're profiting a lot
right now
galvan says traffickers have been able
to smuggle more drugs through the border
because so many agents are focused on
people coming across
if we didn't have as many migrants
coming over at this point in time would
it be harder for them to move the
product
definitely definitely the the fact that
they know
that the migrants eat up a lot of our
time and effort
the dea says the biggest increase is in
fentanyl
the synthetic opioid so potent a
teaspoon
is enough to kill as many as 3 000
people
this is some of the 59 pounds seized in
el paso by texas troopers
the last six months if that almost 60
pounds of fentanyl
had reached the streets and not been
stopped what could have been the result
the result is mass casualty
we cannot afford to stand by and let
fentanyl come across the borders
when it does street level networks use
the interstates to send it across
america
like i-10 to california or i-25 to
colorado
where more than 1300 people died from
overdoses last year
the most in state history
thirty-one-year-old sarah whitner was
one of them
her sister and father speaking out to
help others
i was doing cpr and my own daughter
trying to bring her back knowing that
i probably wasn't going to work we had
to try not something i would ever ever
wish on anyone because that will never
go away
border patrol agent joel freeland says
even with multiple agencies working
together
and advanced technology they're often
outnumbered
they use these opportunities when our
agents are occupied
apprehending these people who are coming
over and that's when they're moving
their drugs at the same time
an escalating war with casualties far
beyond the border
for cbs this morning saturday janet
chameleon
el paso